well it's official New Zealand paid off
the client has given us cock-block hunt
down the militia by any means necessary
hitman is a game about killing people
well killing specific people and trying
not to kill other people unless you
really have to but it's also a game
about exploring large real world and
spide spaces learning about how they
operate finding multiple solutions to
problems and using that knowledge to
improvise and manipulate the environment
to hit the people you hunting the
episodic nature of the Hitman refresh in
2016 so IO Interactive released one
level every month a contentious move at
a time but one that helped accentuate
the potential in each mission hitman 2
ditches the episodic model and adds a
few new minor mechanics but the loop of
continuously replaying a single location
with new objectives slowly uncovering
the wealth of possibilities in the
meticulous sandbox levels and being able
to decide which of your many approaches
is best for your situation in the future
challenges is where hip man remains
strongest hitman 2 takes you to six new
locales and each possesses unique
situations to overcome as you attempt to
assassinate your targets Mumbai is a
standout with its densely populated
streets and labyrinths of tenement
buildings and it's a great environment
that makes the most of a new assassin's
creed style crowd blending mechanic
allowing you to disappear into big
groups of people a mission in Miami
Florida takes place at an active Raceway
a loud and vibrant stage that feels
almost like a theme park of swords with
swaths of attendees distinct zones and a
concealed backstage underbelly these
levels are overwhelming in the best way
possible and it's exciting to begin
peeling away the layers of these large
intricate areas exploring the spaces
discovering roots finding tools and
disguises and figuring out the best
places to utilize them if you're
familiar with hitman you know that each
stage and its AI inhabitants run on
routines like clockwork making hitman a
game that rewards social stealth and
patience eavesdropping tailing and
passive observation are good first steps
to success even the Wilton Creek stage a
small sparsely populated suburban block
in Vermont feels like a mind map of
interconnected causality when you begin
to dig deeper having the curiosity to
uncover how things operate within levels
stumbling upon minor plot lines and
amusing flavor dialogue along the way is
interesting in its own right
PETMAN does make an upfront effort to
help focus just scope and give you some
momentum towards your objectives though
thankfully your initiative is still
necessary to solve some predicaments
stumbling across a mission story
previously known as opportunities might
lead you to a machine you can sabotage
for example but you need to find the
tool to do so and work out the best
method of either distracting or
dispatching the people around it mission
stories are a great first step but
hitman becomes its best when you start
to internalize the stages and uncover
the more obscure ways things can unfold
in subsequent playthroughs be it through
pursuing alternative mission stories
challenges that ask you to perform
specific tasks or your own improvisation
there are a few fail states other than
your own death and there are so many
approaches and tools at your disposal
that the path to victory can be as
creative and elegant or as bumbling and
messy as it needs to be completing a
stage typically takes a long time and
there will be plenty of moments when a
guard catches you doing something you
shouldn't be doing and calls for backup
unhinged gunfights still feel as futile
as ever but when things get out of
control there's almost always an
opportunity to escape to a less hostile
part of the level swap your disguises
and come up with an alternative mcdu
approach in fact hitman is sometimes
more exciting when your initial plans
fail the only problem with being
presented with such a staggering array
of interactions is that the limitations
of the sandbox will eventually reveal
themselves if he pushed the wrong way
for example why can stash bodies and
dumpsters I was disappointed to discover
I couldn't stash them in one of many
vacant portable toilets while I didn't
forty-seven can leap tall fences and
shimmy across daringly high ledges he
seemingly can't muster the courage to
drop down from certain first floor
balconies god AI behavior is Stern but
generous if you're found trespassing in
a restricted area they'll give you a
chance to find the exit before reacting
but sometimes gods are too generous
there was a point where I was amused to
see a targets personal bodyguard decide
to go home for the day after his
employer accidentally fell off a
building even though I was the only
other person in the room hitman 2
continues to embrace a trial-and-error
play style in its campaign the levels
are long but auto-saves are generous and
manual saving is encouraged which gives
you the freedom to experiment with
different ways of approaching a problem
and the closer you get to bending the
systems in just the right way like
trying to narrowly squeeze past the
guards sight line from
different directions or using coins and
cheeseburgers to divert someone's
attention the more thrilling it feels no
matter how goofy it actually looks
Pittman two's interstitial cinematics
are as grim and dramatic as a British
espionage drama and it's hard not to let
yourself buy into the clinical
overarching conspiracy but in the field
the series is tongue-in-cheek absurdity
happily remains with ridiculous costumes
unlikely weapons in agent 47 self-aware
deadpan acting which all perfectly
accompanies any bumbling improvisation
along with the bathroom the kitchen is
the most dangerous room in the home
exists distinctly don't really
complement or detract from one another
but are still enjoyable in their own
rights hitman 2 is a couple of extra
modes but the most exciting bonus at
least if you're in the previous hitman
is the ability to download the original
stages into hitman 2 which gives you
feature complete versions of them with
the addition of new mechanics like
functional mirrors which enemies can
spot you in and the briefcase which lets
you conceal and transport tools
discreetly among other things these
legacy stages are wonderful to revisit
under a new light
the addition of other minor mechanical
changes like concussive weapons a
picture-in-picture enemy activity alert
help to improve hitman 2 overall as a
dense and accessible stealth
assassination game but the new locations
are the real stars impressive and
inventive sandbox is right for picking
apart with exciting experiments hitman
is about experiencing the anticipation
of seeing whether a plan will work when
you try it for the first time it's about
feeling the tension of briskly walking
away from a bad situation hoping you can
lose the suspicious guards it's the
satisfaction of knowing the machinations
of the levels so well that when a target
moves into a particular place at a
particular time you have the perfect way
to intervene hitman 2 is a familiar
experience but in the Hitman world
familiarity is an incredible strength
genius awaits your attention